Last question today.
Hey David, do you believe that Medicare for
all should cover elective cosmetic and plastic
surgery?
So I'm going to answer the question as asked,
but then I'm going to tell you that there's
a major problem with this question.
So during the debates, I often implore the
democratic candidates to immediately call
out questions is problematic when they are
rather than answering them as asked, this
is my show.
So I'll do it in the opposite way.
I'm telling you the question is a problem,
but first I'll answer it as asked.
The term elective is the complicating factor
here.
It's pretty widely accepted that cheek implants
or breast implants for medically unnecessary,
uh, elective cosmetic reasons would not be
covered by Medicare for all that, that you
find very little disagreement with that.
Now, the counter argument would be, you know,
some of these things are medically unnecessary,
but someone's appearance is causing them emotional
distress.
Their nose, uh, is causing them emotional
distress and they're in therapy because of
their nose and it should be covered for that
reason.
It's not the most convincing argument to me,
but that is an argument that is sometimes
made.
Then you get to, well what about cosmetic
surgery?
That's the result of a injury or illness.
And most people say that that should be covered
by Medicare for all.
And I completely agree.
When you get to elective it can get pretty
complicated.
There can be lots of things that are not medically
necessary as typically defined, but they're
not mere vanity.
And the question then becomes where do we
draw the line at elective?
If you need breast reconstruction from breast
cancer, that's a definitive yes.
If you want breast implants for vanity, typically
that's a definitive no.
But what about something like breast lift
surgery for a post-pregnancy condition that
is not life threatening and it's a mix of
medically suggested and for physical appearance,
I don't know.
I mean I lean to, it should be covered, but
these are the sort of middle of the road cases
that ended up becoming a debate.
But now, okay, put all of that aside.
Here's the real analysis.
This is a complete red herring used to distract
from the reality that people already now are
foregoing tons of medically necessary and
preventive maintenance type procedures.
Getting things looked at before they become
serious because of the system that we have
and we already have private insurers making
decisions about what is and isn't covered.
So the problem I have with this question about
whether or not elective cosmetic surgery would
be covered under Medicare for all, is that
it's an attempt to attack Medicare for all
by saying either, wow, you would cover cosmetic
surgery.
That's crazy.
My taxes shouldn't pay for your nose job or
Oh, you won't cover it.
Well, it's not really universal coverage is
it?
And this is the game we shouldn't be drawn
into.
It's a complete distraction.
I'm more than glad to have the conversation
here on the show because I'm answering your
questions and telling you what I think.
But this is a complete and total distraction
from the fact that even if these questions
about cosmetic surgery remain countless, other
issues are resolved by Medicare for all, and
we already have the same type of issues that
people are describing about edge case, middle
of the road, elective cosmetic surgery.
So don't allow yourself to fall for what is
quite frankly, a distraction from the real
debate as to what kind of healthcare system
we should have in the United States that does
it for questions today.
Send yours in, tweet them to me at de Pacman,
send them to me with the subject line audience
questions by using the contact form@davidpakman.com
I'll answer three more next week and make
sure to join me on the bonus show today.
Become a member@joinpacman.com or [inaudible]
the trend at patrion.com/david Pakman show.
They get instant access to the bonus show,
which is coming up right after this, the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com.